this is jockle podcast number 194 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening
as a leader you have to put others
before yourself
and that starts at the beginning and it
starts with everything that you do you
have to let the men eat first you have
to make sure that they have the gear
that they need you have to let them get
rest before you do that's how it works
you have to make sure that they have
what they need to accomplish the mission
and then on top of that you have to make
sure that the mission aligns with the
good of the troops this is hard for some
people to understand but this applies to
any organization the military a business
a sports team and you have to make sure
that the troops understand that there
may be short-term sacrifice there may
even be the ultimate sacrifice in war
men may be killed for the cause but that
cause must be just and that cause must
even in death benefit those who may have
to give that last full measure and that
that may sound impossible actually
because how can anyone benefit from
their own death and the answer is
actually quite simple when military
personnel risk their lives they do so to
provide safety and security for their
country
the country where their families live
and those individuals put their families
above themselves and as a military
leader if you do see that a mission does
not ultimately lead to the safety and
security of the families of the people
that you do lead then it's your
obligation to raise this up the chain of
command and fix it then the same thing
holds true in business as a leader you
must put the good of the troops above
yourself now the thing that might seem
impossible here is that the overarching
measurement of the success of a business
is to be profitable and to maximize
profit one of the things that you do is
you cut costs and one of the easiest
places to cut costs in any business
these people you minimize what you're
paying people or you get rid of people
and then you maximize profit so how can
this leadership principle work how can
you take care of people while at the
same time maximizing profitability and
the answer is that you have to look at
the long game you have to see that the
stronger you build a business the more
long-term stability you build and the
more long-term stability built the more
stability you build for your employees
and when you're stable that allows you
to grow and when you grow your business
the employees have the opportunity for
growth and those opportunities improve
the lives for everyone for the employees
for their family and thereby the whole
community that's what happens but then
what happens when leaders don't put
their people first
in the military it can result in
operations gone wrong it can result in
senseless strategies and in the military
it can result in wasted lives and in
business you can see another kind of
destruction in business it can mean loss
of growth for sure that can mean loss of
revenue yes it can mean loss of jobs but
eventually it can mean the collapsing of
communities the collapsing of cultures
now of course a balance has to be found
and profitability must be maintained but
the dollar must not Trump the people and
it certainly must not regardless of your
capitalistic goals the dollar must not
trump the communities that built the
businesses in the first place the
pursuit of money must not jeopardize the
very fabric of the country that gives us
the promise for the unhindered pursuit
of that money in the first place and yet
we've seen that take place we've seen
that take place in our own country in
cities and in towns and in states where
saving a dollar and then closing a mill
and then shutting down a factory in
places where making more money in the
next financial quarter caused leadership
to forget the long-term impact and sell
the future of those people for cash in
hand in the immediate
and that disease that plague of greed
can spread and it has hurt various parts
of America at various times and when
that's happening while the people at the
top might build themselves a fortune
it's a fortune built on despair and it's
a fortune built on destruction and in
the end that will come back to haunt
them because it is not the right thing
to do and it does not have to be that
way because there are leaders who
recognize the long-term positive impact
of growth and the long-term positive
impact of putting your people first
putting your community first putting
your country first
and one of those leaders happens to be a
business partner of mine happens to be a
friend of mine and his name is Pete
Roberts the founder of origin USA and
once again we are in the woods in the
foothills of Maine's western mountains
for our jiu-jitsu immersion camp which
means it's time for us to record a
podcast and if you don't know Pete
then go back and listen to podcast 93
and then listen to podcast 141 and then
you can rejoin us here because once
again we have Pete Roberts on the
podcast Pete welcome back thanks for
having me that was powerful I was just
you know you get into that rhythm and
I'm just my head's good I just catch
myself going up and down like shit the
way you captured what you just said is I
try to say the same thing I say it
differently but man the impact you know
and in how important community is I know
how important was to New England towns
but it's not just New England towns it's
all towns I mean all people and man
you're absolutely right well with the
with the standard that we're holding at
origin mm-hmm
the standard is made in America right we
see every single day every single day a
corner that could be cut we could make a
compromise and you know what the profit
margins would increase if the profit
margins would increase a little bit and
and every day you and I get to see that
and you're in it you know you're here
you get to see it you know five times a
day eight times a day you see a decision
that could be made you know what hey we
could just get this thing instead and
the profit margins go up a little bit
every day you hold the line yeah and I
think if you you know like the statement
I like to make is well if you if you
follow the truck back to the source
you're gonna end up in a cotton field in
the Tennessee Delta region so if you
that fat your standard the supply chain
is between here and there like like you
said like oh yeah we
like building the boots or the jeans a
little buttons a little brass buttons
the letter tags all these things if you
follow that supply chain back
you're touching not just your local
community but the thousands and
thousands of hands and all the
communities in between that supply chain
and I think that's the easiest place
that you could get rid of some of that
but it's also the most important if it
if you're truly doing something more
than trying to trying to earn your
weight at the top right and I think that
in the past you know we thought we've
discussed this you know in depth in the
past you know and you look at all the
free trade agreements all that stuff
whatever so whatever you know the side
you're on on that thing it was greed it
was greed and the people do the work you
know yeah there's minds at the top you
know and there's minds crunching numbers
and designing stuff but the people do
the work you know and the beautiful
thing that we're doing is we're
resurrecting that heritage and I'll tell
you what I mean we've been together now
what three years and then it's been
about three years and going from what we
started at like ten people I think there
was eight people when I when when I came
when we merged it was eight people so
maybe last year we had 25 people there's
50 people now in the factory 50 people
yeah you know the and I was telling kind
of the crew that's the other day when we
gave the tour you know I'm sitting here
saying this stuff right and and I'm
talking about being greedy and
immediately if you go okay well this
guy's not greedy there's like a there's
like a point where you say okay well
what does he believe in and I actually
in my mind I was thinking that because
here I'm talking about hey you can't be
greedy and then I said listen I am I am
an absolute hardcore capitalist and I
love deal make I mean you you get to see
me now maybe business you know I mean I
love making deals I love making things
happen
I love making money like it's great it's
it's a it's a it's a great contest it's
a great way to keep score you know it's
it's fun right and I'm absolutely a
capitalist but there's such an easy line
to draw so I don't even think is that
hard to try it's not like it still it's
a hard decision to make and oh I don't
know what I should do it's like no
youyou make money but you do the right
thing and you make sure that you're
taking care of people you're making sure
you're making the right decisions and
that's what you do and this is the the
the cool thing about it and this is
where people make the mistake is in the
long run in the long run you'll do
better it's just like leadership just
like leadership if you're taking care of
your people in the long run they're
gonna take care of you and that's gonna
be the the long-term victory is gonna be
better then looking for the short-term
hey i barky if you work for me and i
barky you and you go ahead and do it
right now cuz you don't want to get in
trouble but you're looking for another
job
even though i got you to do what i want
you to do it doesn't matter long-term
I'm gonna lose and when I'm taking
investment away from the people that
actually support the community where we
are then that's just a bad decision in
the long run and again short-term it
looks might look great yeah long term
what does it look like it's a bad deal
it's a bad deal for the community which
makes it a bad deal for the country and
if the if our country is having a hard
time well guess what what have we got
hundred percent
you've got abandoned mills and factories
falling apart in these towns hundred
percent so you just talked about growth
what have you seen from a leadership
perspective you've doubled inside in
size and I know I said to you the other
day has it hey Pete it's gonna get to a
point where you're not gonna be able to
really you know when you got twenty
people we got eight people clearly you
you I mean personal relationships with
families are eight people right exactly
when you got 25 people well now we're
talking cousins and uncles and aunts
maybe you don't know all of them that
well and there's probably that one weird
you know couple you've recruited all you
can yeah yeah like you're there and now
when you get to 50 people well there's
people that you know you you're just
you're just not sure and and you don't
see them every day cuz you're busy
they're busy they're working you're
working so you start to you start to
rely on you have to rely up more on your
leadership team
to carry the message through the company
how's that been for you honestly I'll
tell you and I don't want this to sound
like a you know oh this is this is the
the only thing you should go buy but
dude when we did it when we like when I
pushed extreme ownership I had a stack
of books and all my leadership and
anybody else interested and just hold it
to the leadership about anyone
interested in being part of this company
long term I want you to read this book
I'd recommend you read this book and I
had people say well I don't read never
like cool I'll pay for I'll pay free for
download on your phone I'll give you
cash download it and you know and it's
like well I don't have time oh well put
the headphones on while you're sewing
you know download it you know and I got
I got you so that changed a lot a change
it changed me a lot and we've talked
about this in the past but the biggest
thing is how important for me
decentralized command was the
decentralized command and decentralized
command and the biggest part of that was
I was telling you this the other day
like 7100 what do I mean well you've got
to allow people and empower people and
your leaders to make decisions right and
if you can get them to a 70% decision
which I learned at the muster also you
know and I took if you can get them
there man that's a that's a great thing
it's a great example we're sitting here
in this pro shop at the immersion camp
to get everything here it took it took
five or six trucks I'm talking a 26 foot
u-haul an 18 foot trailer another 24
foot trailer and it took a team of 20
people to get everything here and I took
my wife Amanda to the to the muster in
DC and my father-in-law Joe and Brian
our business partner came and his wife
Megan and in and we went through it and
when you discussed this does it always
have to be a hundred percent like I feel
like I'm gonna make 100 percent decision
maybe that's a little bit of ego talking
you know but I feel like my decision is
always going to be a hundred percent
right and I thought that it was too
dangerous to allow anything less so what
I used to do is I used to flank people
to buy into my idea
mm-hmm you know what I mean like a flank
up to buy into my idea until they until
they could see it but I had to get them
to see it to buy in and now it's it's
different and it's like setting up this
pro shop I know we were it was early in
the morning and everybody's like man
your team's your team's going early
right and I was like yeah they were up
at 5:00 getting everything set up and I
was like but I'm not there right now I'm
hanging back there's a few things I got
to do here to prep and Amanda's handling
and my wife is handling it and I'm like
it's the 70 hundred any like what do you
mean I'm like you know the 70 percent
huh you're like yeah she called me two
hours later we're good to go you know I
was like I don't think I could have
gotten that done in two hours yeah my
hundred percent I don't think I would
have gotten it done in two hours that
maybe would have been another 70 percent
maybe it would have a 65 maybe it would
have been maybe a better than 80 maybe
it'll been an 82 the bottom line any of
that discussion argument did you know
planning would have just wasted valuable
time on both ends yep and but we did do
that we did because I it was the night
before I was like but can you see
logistical e that coming into this camp
in the woods you can't get four trucks
in I'm like you got to be able to see
that you need to if this needs to happen
methodically uh-huh you know so as this
one's unloading and leaving the next
one's coming in so you're saying you did
waste time discussing I did I did and
then you let it go and then I don't go
yep I said I think you've got a good
plan I think that's gonna work let me
know what you need
and I got behind supporting the plan
that's the way that's yeah so there's a
there's a great example of decentralized
grant and so that's not what you've had
to do with everything because you can't
manage it all because this is you know
we work with that echelon front we work
with all different companies but
obviously work with startup companies
and we see this kind of growth and these
are the kind of things that trip
them up they get the guy who's a
visionary like you're the big visionary
and then you start saying well I can you
know I started this thing when I started
this thing I was making every decision
and now all of a sudden you look up and
if you were trying to make every single
decision that was going on the factory
it would be a total disaster
Oh thousand percent what what has
necessitated the D doubling in size this
year and it's not just a doubling in
people because we get people what else
do you need
you need space yeah so we got two more
buildings yeah
and the new the Origin labs facility in
the warehouse that was a super challenge
dude we I don't know if you know
remember on the Instagram I know if you
saw that echo like all of a sudden it
was flooded you know and we had the
spray foam because the illness is in a
extreme environment right extreme hot
and extreme cold during the winter but
we're trying to get everything into the
warehouse it's not insulated we got to
get a heating system in and you know
it's just one of those things where you
just grind and grind and grind but we we
negotiated a great deal on that property
and the next property is gonna allow us
to expand a little more you know and I
think I think that I think we're gonna
have some challenges ahead of us because
we've expanded into three locations but
we've almost created a Bermuda Triangle
of sorts the way that we secured the
locations the facilities it's efficient
it's like lean manufacturing of you know
in between the factories you know the
way you can get from one point to the
next to maximize maximize your time but
you know the labs facility is awesome
and why don't we fulfill this five
hundred to a thousand packages a day out
of there mm-hmm for fulfilling yeah all
leaned out from a shipping perspective
yeah and in the next facility which will
be moving into what next week next week
you want to hang out and move some of
those machines for this where's our girl
actually fat ass we're all the the shoe
manufacturing machinery will be going
screen printing in some rugged materials
so 22,000 square feet there 17,000
square feet in labs and of course were
chewed up 21 thousand square feet
currently so growing quickly and yeah
leadership has been essential and
decentralized command seneschal in that
growth and impossible without it and
senior and I noticed this from early you
know I'd come up and someone to pull me
aside and say you know in chapter 4
you're talking about this you know and
they'd ask me questions yeah and I'd
just be it was such a great sign because
when people don't recognize how
important their job is and how important
they are as a leader that's not that's
just not gonna work but when someone
realizes that they're having a huge
impact with every part of their
department and that their leadership is
the most important thing in that
department
when they realize that and they start
taking ownership of it that has an
impact and that's what it was good
friend I saw that early on I saw that
early on you know we did like a little a
little session and but and people were
asking questions during the session but
afterwards you know people coming up ham
I wanted to ask this in front of
everyone but what do you think about
this how should I handle that and so the
people are aware and that's I think
that's one of the things that has not
saying there's not growing pains cuz I
mean of course there's growing pains but
most of the growing pains are are like
almost like physical growing pains sure
you know like when you leave when your
son grows four inches in six months and
he says you know hey my knees kind of
hurt yeah that's just a physical yes
it's gonna hurt you're growing sorry
dude but as far as you know the
psychological trauma of all the you know
brain damage about this and that the
other thing is very limited right now
which is amazing to see yeah it is and
we're talking about people who weren't
leaders prior to origin mm-hmm you know
nobody had a leadership position nobody
had a management position you know and
the leaders that we've built they're
they're not entitled to it you know it's
weird because you got people who go
through let's say they go to college to
be
business management or leadership or
whatever there is so much potential and
people who just want to work and be part
of something there's so they find so
much motivation in that I would rather
have someone and we're not when I do
like job interviews I say hey I think
one of the first questions are you
looking for a job are you looking for a
career and that's kind of a loaded
question right when I hear I'm looking
for a career okay we're gonna dig deeper
into this conversation now I'd rather
take someone who's looking for a career
that has no leadership skills and give
them the opportunity because I know
long-term they're gonna be an incredible
asset or the company that's the same
theory that we have with EF overwatch
with with hiring vets with bringing that
vets in look a veteran might not have
worked in whatever industry you're in
but that person is hungry they got
leadership skills they got discipline
they and especially the group that we
got we got they they study and train in
extreme ownership and the principles so
they they know how to lead and we're
getting the feedback that we're getting
is phenomenal because people hire
somebody and they go what they you know
they feel like they're taking a little
bit of a risk because the person it's
you know it's this person that was in
the in the army for 21 years or this
person who's been in the whatever
industry the the the gas oil industry
for 21 years and you think well we
should probably just hire the guy that
kind of has experience and we're finding
over and over and over again that guess
what you take that person that's really
hungry that has good leadership skills
they step into that role they learn the
industry specific stuff and they were
and they're rock and roll and I tell
kids this all the time not not kids but
you know college kids college graduates
college graduates if you're that person
that will work hard you can there's so
many companies because I work with so
many companies they there's a drought of
people no one's like hey yep we got all
the good I've never I have never been to
a company where they said yep we got all
the good people we need we don't need
anyone else we don't need anyone other
good people I've never heard anyone say
anything close to that ever even
companies where you know people are
banging on the door to get
in big tech companies that have that
have popcorn machines in the hallways
and pinball that I want to work there
right
there's people banging on the door to
get there you know what those big tech
companies say they say how do you think
we could get better people that are
willing to go hard so it's exactly what
you're saying if you if you look for
someone if you look for somebody ahead
that has that hunger and has that desire
and then they actually have to have it
because believe me there's people like
an interview great and say who you love
to grind what's your biggest weakness my
biggest weakness is sometimes I work too
hard right
that person and then you show up and
they're there and they're in the frickin
Twinkie stash so I'm not talking about I
sometimes I get in the Twinkies - I saw
you getting into the doughnuts - today
bro
are you okay no I'm then I'm good now
you got like insulin spike your face was
sagging sway I was like I'm gonna go lay
down yeah I mean I can literally never
eat a doughnut again if I do I always
think there's gonna be someone with him
with an iphone over there in the corner
and that's gonna be the viral fit the
only viral video of jockle won't be
something that echo made it maybe they
don't need me the doughnut may be my
video of you eating the doughnut that
wouldn't want that would be a that would
be a major kind of situation that we'd
have to discuss yes like treasonous yeah
yeah that would be I've
I haven't been betrayed very much in
fact I've only been betrayed one time
but if that I would consider that weed
after we'd have to put that at any
number that would be a consideration of
betrayal yeah I don't think oh don't
worry therefore we're because I'm not
eat doughnuts yes sir did you have any
baklava the other thing yes
how many pieces - two pieces that's good
start how many did you feed me oh dude I
would just kept shoveling
I hope think you even know you're
thinking what is what is like the sweets
like part they're done of the moist like
they're really like almost wet part
that's like that the honey okay sugar
syrup
but you know that's a special recipe
yeah you know we were when we were with
the Harry's died we were in New York
City and Harry Steakhouse we're eating
with Harry and we sent him baklava
uh-huh and my mom she she called me and
she's like you sent baklava to New York
City to a guy who owns a big restaurant
oh yeah she goes you didn't send the
recipe did you and I was like no no I
just have to pocket she was upset yeah I
had like sent him the recipe to make the
baklava it is it is legit a secret
recipe and there's one thing that she
does to make it as good and I'll tell
you what it is after the podcast jack
it's no one else does it yeah it's an
old Spartan laughs yeah there you go
that's Pete's mom's special recipe
okay so there's got to be demand there's
got to be up something driving this
growth obviously you know and it's been
a it's been a continual kind of rapid
rapid can't eat there's just continual
product invention for lack of a better
word yeah and and one of the things in
and you and I were talking this morning
I was holding I was putting on us
getting another rift key yeah and I know
not everyone does jujitsu but the rift
key is like it's like a complete it's
it's like a new product it's like it
doesn't exist until now and it's weird
to say that about I guess it'd be I
don't know what's a good what's a
clothing product that like completely
changed like it didn't exist it now it
does well I would say that's easy that
that would be the compression shirt
Under Armour came out with because we
both play college football remember we
had the grays
the Cotton's the concerts in the cotton
shorts and you wore that cotton t-shirt
underneath football pads and then Under
Armour came out with the football shirt
and it changed it changed it up now you
wouldn't you're not gonna play with this
whole thing anymore never wear anything
else again right and that's what the
rift is like you're not you're not gonna
what you're not gonna go oh cool I'm
just gonna wear another key today
because I have it notes no I just I'm
just gonna wear this key the the the
whole thing is engineer
brand-new yeah right you I did you did
was the football jersey thing like was
that an inspiration for coming up with a
rift I absolutely absolutely because the
performance like we developed this poly
synth fiber we know what I'd like to say
is you know we we didn't just
manufacture it we synthesized to this
thing you know I mean like it's
synthesized and we you know I don't I
don't know if I told you how much money
we spend on developing this you might
have kept that from me
I probably just didn't tell you but you
know we had a I think I told you we had
to order a new batch of yarn we had and
you've got to set up the friggin loom
and there's three thousand ends right
and it and it takes 60 hours to set it
up and and we had to have the yarn spun
and then we did it and we're like it's
not good enough so you have all these
prototypes you know we've got to get rid
of now we've got to get the yarn again
they were like it's not twisted strong
enough it's pilling too much we need to
talk the ends you know you're talking
these little freaking fibers individual
fibers you know and well it's not
abrasion resistance enough and so you
know when you take away the garment
itself and the cotton the spiral wrap
and how it functions on your body and
you go right back to the fiber that's
where we had to start you know we had to
start from that point and then develop
the weave the dragon weave gen3
and it's hard to explain unless you put
it on of course you were down there
again like King Arthur you put it on you
know and you're like wow wow this thing
is just ridiculous
yeah and not what's by the way fresh out
of the package yeah when you take any
piece of clothing fresh out of the
package it well in my opinion it all
sucks coming out of the package when you
take another package man you know this
doesn't this thing is out of the package
it's brand-new and you put it on and it
feels like it feels like it's been
skinned a unicorn yeah
yeah it was something like that so so
that's like an example of product moving
forward making things and this is the
the other kind of thing that is
happening because of our sport stuff has
to be extremely durable right so you're
making something that just doesn't feel
good because you can make something that
feels good it has to be durable and
that's the tricky part right because if
you look at the way they make things
soft or to feel good against the skin
usually what that means is they're
deteriorating the textile a little bit
right they're breaking it down so that
those fibers touch your skin and they
feel all smooth and comfortable and we
couldn't deteriorate the strength of the
garment so we had to find a way to do
that with the yarn that's the keys find
a way to make the yarn comfortable and
then the weave and then make the garment
form around your body and the way I
explain this like if you took a if you
took a baseball or lacrosse ball and you
took this piece of paper and you wrapped
it around see if you can get it smooth
can you get a smooth no you're gonna
have wrinkles all through it right and
and that's what basically every key on
the planet is like all right now if you
take that same piece of paper and you
just strip it into straight strips and
then you start wrapping those strips
around that ball what you're gonna get
you're gonna get a smooth surface and
that's why we call it the spiral wrap
because it strips that spiral around
your body you know in seven seven panels
and yeah it's innovative I don't know if
there's another it shouldn't exist the
garment shouldn't exist yeah so coming
off of that and while you're working on
that and I'm all this is coming home
from a trip where I was up here and
seeing the factory and being you know
just kind of up in that spiritual high
from seeing our people American people
working hard like dedicated like
passionate about doing good like just
seeing everything in action and I was
flying home and I remember I was late
over somewhere and I'm sitting in the
airport and I'm just looking at everyone
while I'm sitting there and I see that
and I called you and I said hey Pete man
and you said yeah
and I said how many people do you know
that you that do jiu-jitsu and you're
like um I don't know a hundred and I was
like cool how many people do you know
that wear jeans and you said everyone
and I said I'm in the airport right now
and eight out of ten people are wearing
jeans I remember that conversation we
need to make jeans and you go I've
always wanted to make he said I've
always wanted to make jeans and that was
the opening of a whole new game right a
whole new market and a whole new world
from that conversation what was the next
step from there you know when we had
that conversation and I don't know I you
might have told me this fact in America
there's 300 million Americans you know
how many Americans actually Owens jeans
298 million 298 million people own jeans
and there's two million Communists that
don't you know it was uh
I knew we could make the product you
know and honestly like I always wanted
like I couldn't fit forward nice jeans
as a kid you know I remember going into
the Banana Republic or the gap and
basically looking at stuff and trying it
on and you know for kids my mom you know
$24,000 a year with four kids she just
didn't have a lot of extra and we would
get like one nice thing before the
school year started and of course school
starts for our kids my daughter started
school today you know and I think about
what she has and what you know the heart
what hard work has allowed us to do for
the kids to start school with the new
pair of sneakers and some clothes and I
think about like jeans have always been
important to me because we couldn't
afford them and it was it
is always the it wasn't just the style
of it but it made you feel alive and
made they made you feel free you know
and they've always represented that I
mean in digging into denim in around the
globe not just America if you start
connecting denim you see they represent
like the freedom revolution independence
empowerment right they represent these
things and I was so damn excited you
were on board with it I just like yes I
think it was just like yep you just
needed a little you were like
Frankenstein just needed a little spark
yeah you know when the coach night well
you know as is it exactly exactly just
turn it on because you know managing you
know all these people managing you know
the factory a couple locations and the
growth right of course you don't want to
make mistakes you still gotta be a
little bit naive enough to think you can
you can do it though
and I knew we could do it because we've
been making this stuff for combat sports
we've been making products that people
are yanking on ripping at pulling
wrapping around arms and heads with and
I knew we had to set up to make durable
goods and denim was to me it was like
well if we make this it will be the most
durable jeans ever made because we're
gonna apply the same techniques and
concepts we've developed for the past
six years manufacturing stuff for combat
sports and we're gonna apply the same
thing to this and that's what we did and
we just did it man I mean I don't even
know how to explain it I go I mean we
got leaves our pattern maker and we just
started I started having to work and I'd
overnight you sample side of the back
we're hoping the first ones weren't
amazing they were but honestly like got
the textile right you know American
cotton a little bit of stretch you know
modern but still super durable and then
we started sewing it together with those
three needle like chain stitch machines
you know what you just don't find
anymore
no you know you just don't you don't
find it it's hard because we're gonna go
with two needles then you cut your cost
of thread by
and done anything if you go into the
store and look at what they actually
have it's usually just one threat yeah
the seams you know it's just one one
machine so and it's easy to cut cost
like that and is just like well that's
just not what we're doing
so it was challenging you know I think
it's not just developing the product
because you can and this is across the
board when you're starting something new
even though we've been making all these
keys and stuff for jiu-jitsu it's still
a different product and there's still
style you still have to have some type
of style and you know call that form
right well there's there's like jeans
out there and it's all all all form
right and then you've got stuff that's
just simply function right and the idea
is you've got to balance those two
things out you can't be too over-the-top
too extreme it's just like balancing out
leadership I mean it's really the same
thing form and form function the balance
of those two things you know and we
didn't get it right right off you know
and you're like you're like bro this
yoke here in the back you know there's a
riser in the back just just not doing it
for me you know it's weird too for me
because I never paid attention to it
before right you noticed that never yeah
no assumed such as soon as I got it I
was looking at other jeans that I had
and saying okay here's what's different
I remember said I'd be unlike sending
you pictures or here's I didn't even
know you what a yoke was but I realized
it's like the part below the waistband
where it gives you a little separation
between the legs of the pants and I
didn't never paid attention to before in
my life but I looked at I was like hey
this seems like it's a lot longer than
mine right now is there a benefit to
that and you're like well here's the
benefit and I said well here's the
negative the negative I'm gonna pack I
got a a pocket on my hamstring right now
instead of on my ass cheek which is
where it needs to be for my form and
function right so then it's okay we can
tighten that up so the the the other
thing that's weird about it that no that
I definitely don't think about is when
you make it and you say okay this is
what we are going to produce and you
pull the trigger on that like that's
what you're gonna get so it
be good it's kind of like I do relate in
the fact that when you publish a book
and you're gonna print a hundred
thousand copies and then you open it up
and you find a mistake
that's that stings and that's that
stings and that's what happened
you know the firt those right behind you
right there yeah we went into production
and they're coming off a line right we
trained everybody and I thought we were
good to go initially but they started
coming off the line and we weren't used
to working with you know we're used to
working with like compression textile
because for all the rash guards and
stuff we make but not a woven we're used
to working with knits we've never worked
with a woven so all of our machines were
set up for rigid right textiles that
don't stretch and like the first like
few hundred pairs that came off we
started to look at them more intently
and we found that we made some mistakes
and the mistake was somehow it was the
the fabric was starting to grow Oh grow
it was growing because and this is
something machines will never be able to
do yeah all right
machines aren't people they can't they
can't make adjustments on the fly you
can only program a machine to do a task
and it can do that one task well but it
can't recognize when there's something
wrong and then make an adjustment right
it's gonna do one thing one speed one
way that's a beautiful thing about
humans right and in manufacturing to do
it right if they want to do it right and
that's it that's a key thing right there
they've got to want to do it right
because they could just keep rolling
even though there's a problem and just
keep cranking and this happens a lot
this happens when you say you're growing
what does that mean the textile that the
garment was growing because it was
either being held too hard or the
tension of the machine and what we found
is a mixture of both okay you know
because we're used to making these room
you know the stuff for jiu-jitsu so
you're holding it and as as they were
holding it the
the textile was growing cuz it was a
little bit of lycra in it got it it was
grow the whole thing was growing so that
the 32s were coming offline and they're
like thirty Six's so we had to make some
adjustments on the fly had to change the
patterns recut a batch of denim and we
just and you know it was the right move
we just didn't release it mm-hmm we're
just like no that's a big tuition
payment that's just it's just gonna be a
tuition payment you know and push
forward I mean and some of them had did
that is that what cause like the twist
and the seem like to my son my son has a
pair like one of these original ones and
he's you know I look I looked at him was
like yeah look at the thing he's like I
don't care because he's at school do you
think I don't care about what I look
like my son is just like don't care yeah
he's like these are the best jeans I'm
just wearing him anyway so the seam on
the outside of his leg roles with words
his shin in the front on one leg we
found an old yesterday an old research
paper from like the 40s leg twist in
jeans was the title of it no kidding and
so what what was the cause of that my
old pattern maker Lisa she's 63 64 she
found the paper she brought it into the
factory and it's a whole research thing
like a college research leg twist in
jeans what it is is that as the textiles
being woven that it's called a twill and
there's a you know diagonal lines if you
look at the jeans diagonal lines in
order to cut jeans effectively to not
get leg twist you have to cut them in
pairs and those pairs have to be
reversed opposite and we found that out
after close to a thousand pairs yeah leg
twist in jeans so you talk about
manufacturing a product as simple as
jeans and I mean what did it take us
before we launched it I mean we did it
fast man like what six months yeah yeah
we're you're sending me pairs pretty
quick just launching yeah so we finally
got to figured out when we got them
launched and I don't you know they're
freaking phenomenal I don't know what
else to say about the product itself but
man those those ladies worked
I'm saying ladies because our whole that
whole floor is all women between the
ages of 20 and 60 mmm and it's awesome
seeing Millennials work that wanna work
yeah
okay like you know ten of them on that
floor cranking your ranking and yeah
working together and just like a beehive
man just like a frickin beehive walking
in that place in the morning we're gonna
I don't know if you want me to say this
or not but I'm about to we're gonna make
another pair of jeans that's gonna be
lighter weight now echo Charles you'll
just for your FYI mm-hmm the jaco me I
am requesting lightweight jeans okay
yeah
kind of weird dichotomy yeah that cotton
is don't want the lightweight hoodie
want the lightweight jeans yeah Kenneth
do you want to know why yes how many
times my legs have been cold you know
how many times I've been like oh I I
don't want to be outside anymore because
my legs are cold it's never happened
okay you know I used to wear shorts all
the you know all year long there's
snowing outside I wear shorts okay so
let lightweight chains that'll be the
next next thing we're gonna make and and
we've got a little tie back to my
heritage in the Navy in the SEAL Teams
because in the in Vietnam the issued
fatigues weren't durable enough for the
combat operations that the seals were
doing and so many of the seals in
Vietnam War jeans and so we're gonna
make some jeans we've got a cool name
for him
that I will not reveal okay let it rip I
was like I'm waiting for ya
it's too cool but you know the legacy
and we just the last podcast would you
haven't heard yet that we just did with
a seal master chief named Kirby her L
who is just as completely legit as they
come as frogmen and yeah he you know he
was talking about wearing jeans and Nam
and so yeah so we've got that we've got
these lightweight jeans coming I think
that's gonna be an I already
have actually already have three pairs
sorry well I I have a pair I've been
I've been testing the Goods myself so I
spent 30 days in Europe last month I put
200 miles on the boots and I think it
was 20,000 miles on the jeans as we
traveled and man those things are
getting worn in fading in and just the
abrasion of movement and motion in life
it's awesome dude it's freaking awesome
so and you know people like why are you
so damn excited about jeans
well 298 million Americans own jeans
because they're cool but it's really
what they represent you know and I
learned something recently that you know
after the great before the Great
Depression yeah I can go into an old
antique store and you see the trunks and
they got the stickers all over oh man
the postcards you know well people were
traveling to Europe before the Great
Depression they were going on vacation
for they'd go for like a month or two at
a time right and then the Great
Depression happened and every everybody
just kind of hunkered down and they
didn't feel confident enough to go on
these voyages right ships these voyages
so what they decided to do is go and
explore the American West and what I've
heard is that the Cowboys out there or
wearing denim blue jeans in in the idea
and I'm digging into this through
research is that that's where fashion in
jeans started in the u.s. so the city
slickers from the east when out west saw
the free-range cowboys and say yeah and
and took that free spirit attitude back
to the East Coast and there you go I
still got to prove it but that's your
theory
yes yes now I remember this do you
remember do you remember like the Berlin
Wall do you remember East Berlin as well
as I do I know you know about it yes I
do but I didn't get it I remember
watching the wall come down it was 89
I was 10 years old 11 years old maybe
and I absolutely remember it I remember
man I remember honestly feeling unsure
because I didn't understand why these
men would these sledgehammers were
slamming that wall with such anger and
then elation didn't register and I
remember the conversation in the house
of my parents talking about freedom and
communism and I had no idea what these
concepts I didn't know anything about
them but then when the wall came down
and they were accepted into the and
their friends and family watching them
come across I was just like they've been
separated I just remember that not
knowing what communism won it was their
separation or anything I just remember
that they were they were they were in
prison basically yeah and yeah of course
I was there last month so I yeah because
what I remember when I was a kid you
know at my school like kids would go on
like a school trip to wherever England
or Spain or something like that like the
Spanish class there'd be kids that would
go on a school trip and what people
would say is like you kind of bring
jeans bring jeans you can sell them yes
you can sell them and there was like a
black market to get those things into
the Eastern Bloc countries you could
sell a pair of American you know
standard American jeans that cost $16 at
the grocery store at the department
store and you could bring them over and
sell them for $100
I remember hearing that $100 and I had
like two pairs of jeans or three pairs
of jeans and I'm thinking hey can you
take these can you try and get a lot
great dollars for these things and that
was and that to me has always said that
those people over there identified blue
jeans like the like you're saying the
East Coaster dude look at the cowboy and
said that's the spirit of freedom right
there and you know
the thing is is you know when I get into
something I go deep that's why we ended
up building a factory in my backyard but
I needed I need to understand more about
why jeans represented revolution anyways
we were in East Berlin last month and
working on this project doing some
research and I sat down with a woman who
lived in East Germany her dad was a spy
and you know they had and I didn't
realize this they had access to the West
in terms of the news and the media and
everything it wasn't like they were
closed off from that and I think that
might be a misconception they could see
it but they couldn't touch it right so
it's almost like like they're in a cage
and they can see what's happening
outside but they can't they can't touch
it and so we we sat down and we had
dinner in this old Russian restaurant
and it was it was like this this scene
like you'd see in a movie or something
you know with the yellow lights and all
the pictures on the wall and we're
sitting there intimate like this having
dinner and she told me about growing up
in the East and as she got into the
conversation she reached in her doll in
her bag and pulled out her diary from
her childhood and she's like let me show
you something and she opened the diary
and there was a tag in there a Wrangler
tag and she said this was my from my
first pair of jeans and this tag was
beat up and worn in and and her jeans
deteriorated but she saved that tag and
then she flipped the page and in her
diary she was she had a little bit this
woman's name is Anya Anna and and her
friend had gone in New York City and she
had written you know in a girl's diary
and she has jeans then she took the pen
and she underlined it and she took a
highlighter and she highlighted it she's
like I didn't really understand how
important it was to me
until you and I started talking because
we had talked the day before and she
said the first time in my life I ever
feel empowered as an individual was when
I got my first pair of jeans when I was
13 and I put them on that first time I
had only worn dresses what they gave us
to wear yeah and I put those jeans on
for the first time and I felt free and
if you want to distill this thing down
why it's so important look at that you
know what I just realized
so I have a I have a ten-year-old
daughter and she's been wearing your
daughter might be too old for this trend
but a lot of girls right now that are
younger maybe six seven eight nine they
were basically a matching kind of whole
polyester like dry-fit type outfit like
that's the whole thing right and it all
matches it looks like a weird tie-dye
looking thing and you know my daughter
must have had like three or four of them
and she would just rotate them like
that's just just just what and turn all
of her friends they look like somebody
spilled crayons everywhere okay and
that's what they oh that's kind of like
and I think from a mom's perspective you
know it's really easy you know just
there you go you know just wear this and
my other daughters and my other
daughters took her shopping and when she
came home she says dad I'm gonna go put
on some of the clothes I got and she had
it she was she came out and she was
wearing a pair of jeans and it was her
first pair of jeans believe it or not
Wow cuz we live in California there's no
we don't wear jeans out there we work
shorts or if you're a eight-year-old
girl you wear these outfits these
matching little what is it nylon is that
what it is what is it I don't know does
P wear of those things yes okay he's
like wait is that a romper yeah wrong
yeah well it's like that but it's all
it's like a wool it's just a outfit and
every little girl well yeah there's a
lot of them so my daughter comes out of
her room and you know what she's ten you
know and she's tall for a ten-year-old
but all of a sudden she had
and I could see now that you're I'm
connecting you know she looks so proud
and you know kind of like she was
standing up straight like she was now in
you know in the big leagues kind of and
she you you know that time you go
through in your life where you're like
I'm a person yes she looked like she had
that kind of I'm a person I'm an
individual I'm a I'm a person
I got I'm I'm here confident yes I'm
here yeah
the I'm not mama's little girl anymore
yeah and how much that comes from my
daughter's going you need to get genes
you know what I mean you need to get
genes yeah that's in my that's in my
kids psyche that you you know what you
get genes and that's when you become an
individual human ready to take on the
world
that's not that's so cool and it is
crazy because it really does you know it
really does like it just you know when
you wear something like and that's the
that's the important I mean it's it's a
beautiful thing really you know to that
you can be empowered by something on
your body
mmm-hmm you know and people say well
that's that's not it's not important you
know what you wear well it's really not
important what you wear but it is
important how you feel about yourself
you know it is important how you project
yourself you know I mean if your if your
work of rationale on front going
somewhere you know you were a teacher if
you were on Fox News what do you put on
yeah I put on a suit why because that's
what you put on that's right right I
think that's important I think the next
time I might be going on I might be
wearing some more this is what I this is
something else I just realized think
about this okay do you have a you get a
pair of slacks right get a pair of
slacks what's another word for that
pants trousers trousers or whatever you
get a pair of pants those if you get a
normal pair of pants or whatever they
they'll change a little bit over time
but basically the change that they go
through deteriorates them and they're no
longer usable but
jeans are different jeans wear and they
become comfortable and they've come to
your body they like they like they
weren't or not yes they were yes they
were in not out but they become yours
like you can't if one if you have a nice
pair of jeans that's broken and they
you've had for a while and something
happens to him you have to go get
another pair you have to go through a
period of time we're either they're not
quite your jeans yet and you know what's
crazy is is that woman Hanyu was I was
with she she was told me she's like you
know they they tried to make jeans
because eventually you didn't have to
smuggle them in anymore eventually you
if you knew somebody outside they could
ship you the jeans if they could afford
them right so they became so popular
that east-berlin government decided East
Germany government decided we're gonna
make jeans and they did they made jeans
and I picked up a pair of those jeans I
found someone who had a pair and they
weren't jeans they didn't know how to
weave the textile and they couldn't
figure it out
so what were they were they just like
some weird fabric like it was a weird
fabric and it wasn't even indigo died so
they would never they wouldn't even fade
in they were just like blue material
material yeah yeah it was it was crazy
so it failed miserably and she said so
the government imported a million pairs
of American jeans and they sold out like
the like the day they arrived that's the
kind of thing where you realize that's
why communism doesn't work yeah because
the state can't figure it out you know
but the individuals can so give them
some jeans and let them run wild now
okay jeans we got that we might have
gone a little bit I don't know a little
ripped
all right now the other thing you said
is you put miles on boots yeah now this
is a little bit of a reversal role where
I said to you like hey bro everyone
wears jeans you said to me hey man we
need to make boots and that made me that
made me nervous because I look at boots
I said hey man like these are everyone's
feet are different it's hard to make and
it's you gotta the sizes I mean they're
you can't ham a pair of boots like boots
are what size they are and and and
people complain about blisters and you
know in a seal platoon
everybody wants a different kind of
boots so I was definitely more hesitant
on the on the just the product itself
and then on the manufacturing to me it
just seemed like a crazy thing and you
like you were laughing I don't know if
you remember this you're laughing you're
like you laughing you like bro it's so
much easier to make boots and it is to
make to weave fabric on a loop yeah and
I think some of that laughter was more
like I'm ready for the challenge you
know what I mean like this is the thing
is is you know just in full transparency
you know you and I had a private
conversation at the end of last year and
like okay what are we gonna do you know
what are we gonna do to grow and we
wanted to make the investment you know
of our profit and put it back into the
company and and we're identifying where
we want to grow right and what's gonna
have the biggest impact on the community
but also what the community can handle
right and we know they can handle making
denim blue jeans and I knew the
community could not only handle but but
if we could make Footwear again I just
need to clarify this when you're talking
about the community what you're talking
about is the actual community within
which you live within which our factory
is within which we have a pool of people
that's the community that actually have
this skill set and that's the part that
I didn't appreciate and as soon as you
you were like hey because I'm thinking
along how are we gonna make shoes you
said we've got the people and then I
growing up of course who was up here all
these massive shoe manufacturers were up
here and I said oh yeah obviously okay
check run exactly exactly in I mean shit
I mean Newton New Balance is still in
Maine doing some stuff
Nike used to be in vain you had you had
bass shoe right you had Dexter shoe you
had Haydn shoe Allen Edmonds I mean you
had all these brands and and one of our
employees Christine she actually was the
one who went to the Dominican when the
free trade agreements went into play and
trained them on she was the best little
way stitcher in the country she trained
them how to use that machine so she was
part of let's call it a brain drain a
skills drain right where the skills
needed to go away what happens when they
go away she's the only one left with
those skills right and I had identified
a few people with those skills and these
old shoe dogs one of them was Bart
Hershey you know and this old guy rollin
land shoe dog is the name of that book
is that a term anyways shoot off your
dogs yes it is it there's a book written
that's by the guy that made Nike exactly
yeah shoot up but that's a common term
he didn't corn no no that's what these
guys are he was part of that or God all
these guys helped him get started
this guy Rowland is the one that helped
Kimberlin start he's the one that had
the machinery and the knowledge to get
Timberland so they could mold a soul
onto a leather upper he developed that
and so I had all these old-timers who I
had just honestly I didn't give an
opportunity not to not to meet me like I
just go to their factory call him on the
phone you know show him what we're doing
and get in front of him get in front of
him get in front of him and then finally
we started building relationships and
this this one guy Rowland I went over
there and and he had to get rid of some
machinery and we did some kind of
negotiating and I was like what do you
what do you want you know yeah I've got
to figure out what somebody wants yeah
you know we ended up negotiating he's
like can you do a lobster bake from my
staff
and I said yeah he goes take it all
loaded up a tractor trailer of machinery
as small it's like a 20 foot you know
and a couple weeks ago Joe my
father-in-law and I and a few other guys
from the factory went out and cooked his
whole staff a lobster bake lobster bake
for old shoe machinery but these shoe
dogs so shoe dog is the term that is
just used it's a general term for
someone who's been in the industry for a
long time but you know as we were
talking at the other last year and you
know I kind of put your I guess concerns
that ease a little dinner for you know
it's like we can make shoes yeah you
know we don't have to reinvent anything
even though we need to build it from
scratch there's a difference there yeah
you know if we're gonna like try to
figure it out and not have the knowledge
that would be one thing but the
knowledge has only been it's only been
removed for 20 years right if it had
been removed for 50 years I'm not gonna
say it's impossible you know I would
have taken a lot larger effort and a lot
bigger a lot more costly tuition yes
anyways and I and in the effort right
now has been great and in the in the
expense has been great I mean we're in
month eight and this week we're finally
ready to really launch that as you saw
in the factory the other day but you're
talking about okay Jocko got Jacko's
blessing you know the teams on board
what are we gonna do I hired one person
one person Henry and he'd been in the
industry for 40 years and he started
January 1st I gave him a piece of paper
with how I wanted the boot to look and I
said this is what we want to build now
just just so you know everyone
understands I know you get it that we're
talking about starting something from
scratch all right we don't have any
machinery we don't have asses in seats
which is my way of saying human
resources
we don't have the workflow we don't have
the raw materials we don't have the
patterns we don't have to go to highs
zero fee I gave him a piece of paper
with an illustrator drawing and said
this is what we want to make that's
crazy
not really hmm not really crazy because
if you can see when you when you see
people work together where each one has
a skill set in end and I know this is
like on the SEAL Teams like I'm sure
when you did operations and everything
was just moving it's like a perfect for
it like a Russian ballet it's like a
perfect flow of organization right and I
had seen it in the rest of the factory
and how we did the rest of the factory
and that's why I knew we could do it but
I but I also knew that the challenges of
building something for a foot you know
that that a foot everyone's feet are
different in their crotch shape they're
asymmetrical you know it's a strange
thing a foot I knew we were gonna have
chattering this is a symmetrical yeah
they're not the same they're not the
same I knew we were gonna have
challenges and I know I haven't told you
about all the timid tuition payments but
I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna tell you
about a couple that I may have skipped
what happened all my money so we we got
into it and you know and we made some
boots you know to start off but it was
all you know Henry with an x-acto knife
like hand cutting everything whatever
and we started building the patterns
they weren't perfect so you gotta
imagine like eight months we're now into
this thing eight months once once we
actually got a boo of course he started
with a 14 wrong and that would bite us
in the ass
six months down the road that was that
was the tuition payment I wanted him to
start with a 14 because I wanted to wear
it first
not knowing that six months down the
road that would be a mistake because you
never grade grading is how you scale
everything you never grade from your
largest size
you always grade from the middle
from the middle-sized yeah so I should
have made your size first you asked me
to cuz I knew just ask me that question
I would have said oh yeah because you
probably lose a little bit of the you
lose a little bit that shape and the and
the the what's the word the rings yeah
the ratios as you go up exactly that's
what grading is you know so we needed
all those things patterns to fit the
foot leather we needed the knowledge of
course clicker dies to cut the material
but most of all we need shoe making
machinery so which these are very
specialized incredibly specialized very
specialized and it wasn't feasible to
just buy new stuff you know I mean would
it have been smartest to buy all new
machinery yes hmm yes it would have been
it would have been smartest if we wanted
to take that risk and dump that amount
of capital in of it I was gonna say
because it doesn't seem like that would
be real sorry exactly but you know what
I knew I knew that Henry used to be a
mill right and that if we could just get
decent machinery even old machinery that
was running he could keep it running and
our little proof of concept called
bringing back shoe manufacturing and
Franklin County Maine if we could prove
that concept it would be only a matter
of time to be able to invest in in that
new machinery so that's what we did we
talked about it how much it's gonna be
pal ah all right let's do it
so I ended up calling this old-timer mo
he's the one that found our first loom
so I went back to the source mo this is
what I want to do and he's wild you know
this guy he he told me a story uh you
you ever heard of Dexter shew of course
there was a man named Harold Alfond
no Harold alfon built Dexter shoe he
built it he was working at another shoe
company he built it by loading machines
that weren't being used like in the in
during the night time into his station
wagon
and driving them to a mill in Dexter he
basically took the machines that were
like the abandon machines from this
other factory and he started the factory
and he built an empire all right Harold
Alfond he got bought out by Berkshire
Hathaway they had a contract that when
Harold Alfond died they could move
Dexter shoe out of Maine
Harold Alfond died a few years back they
shot the factory down and moved it out
of me
this shit just a man it gets to me it
gets to me mo told me a story about
about Harold al Fonda because Moe's dad
was an old shoe dog and he made the
parts for the machine then he said Pete
let me tell you something you're gonna
need my help doing this this is what I
do
this guy Harold Alfond he started this
Factory and he couldn't he could he
wasn't getting it he wasn't making any
money
and he called my dad and he said can you
come up to the factory and this is back
when it doesn't matter if this small
time are trying to build this the shoe
company hasn't even started selling
product yet it's in the hole maybe it
has a handful of employees this guy's mo
his dad drives up to Dexter two hours
sits in front of Harold Alfond and
Harold Alphonse says can you buy these
box of parts back from me I'll buy them
back from you
in three months and his dad said yeah
I'll take him back took the parts back
gave him the money
three months later Harold Allen pot
impact this guy's worth I don't know a
billion dollars now but this this thing
of sitting in front of somebody and
having a conversation and building
relationships what I found in this shoe
making thing is the most important thing
because these are still the guys running
it the same guys running it in the in
the dudes
these shoe dogs that have been in the
factory helping us combined age 88 90
and we've probably had a dozen in there
and you should see their freaking
eyeballs when they walk in they don't
want to leave honestly on occasion
bringing tears to their eyes that that
this is what we're doing because they
saw it they were part of it and they saw
it leave and just that spark man like
you know I'm honestly just hit me hits
me right in the fields man that spark
they see it's motivation and I
absolutely knew that with their support
it was going to be possible and so we've
been grinding this is the first pair of
boots that that I got that you sent me
the first pair that beachy sent me was
better than the first pair of jeans she
sent me that that was a shocker to me
like it was like take him out of the box
I was like no way this is ridiculous and
and you know you're like hey there's
there these aren't perfect from sent him
just so you can look at him and I was
like no I'm wearing him I've been I was
wearing him out of the box
comfortable crazy yeah that was crazy
I was like bro what's wrong with your
jeans dude you got like we had to figure
out how to make jeans you know what I
mean
whereas we had the knowledge base to
make the foot wear like it was still
here you know and man I mean these guys
came in and they just like dumbed their
knowledge on but Henry Henry being the
key in this guy MO and so I'm like I
need machinery so he found all the old
machinery overseas he brought it back
over on us really bringing machinery
that's been shipped overseas
along with the jobs literally we're
bringing it back to America you know
actually happening actually happening
machines designed in New Hampshire knit
machines designed in Massachusetts
manufactured right there bringing them
back these old machines and Moe
refurbished them and now they're in the
factory and it's badass
so what's that where we at right now I
know we have
the the leather for 400 500 pairs yeah
you know we connected with the tannery
that's 45 minutes away that's nothing
about supply chain right there's one
tannery left in Maine and they just
happen to manufacture all the leather
for the military boots so we went up to
them and they're like we'll we'll help
you guys however we can so they're
canning leather for us
they're tanning 7000 leather and it took
a while to get it right I mean it's you
got to remember like leather like
textiles depending on how its tanned it
can be you know can stretch more be more
rigid and not form right it can wrinkle
you know there's there's all sorts of
shit that can happen that that's really
bad so anyways we had to get through all
of that and we had to get through that
and make sure the patterns were right
and then we ordered the dyes and we
started cutting and it was wrong
because we had graded them from the
fourteens so we may have lost 10 or 15
grand how dyes I know but uh but we we
reordered the dyes and now we've got
them working but um but yeah so we have
probably 500 pairs cut ready ready to go
and we lean manufactured out the line
and we're in the process of training the
young folks now we have a young girl
Nikki she's 19 another guy who's in
there Christine and Henry those two with
combined experience like 80 years you
know the little wastage I was telling
about and Henry and we're like what
literally once you and I have a
conversation like hey should we turn it
on we'll just turn it on mmm we'll turn
it on and we need to turn it on in the
factory right now before we move it you
know to the new plant because it's got
it's got to work there first we got to
have the proof-of-concept worked out but
man I put I put a ton of miles on those
boots and man they're wearing in nicely
yeah nicely so it's it's a
classic is what boots it's like boots
that's what they are they're boots boots
pants hey you know what they go well
with jeans yeah I love the fact that we
like we're calling the jeans legit fit
now while we're doing all this meanwhile
out starting jockle publishing you know
I have a comic hey man by the way I've
got you know whatever I'm gonna be I got
a hundred thousand books that you know
I'm gonna need to get moved from place
to place we have a fulfillment center
it's like you're like yes we do and boom
all of a sudden next II know where we
got a fulfillment center we got a
warrior Kid 3 we got miking the Dragons
there you're we just absorb that it was
like it was one of those things that a
lot gave me the freedom to tell my
publisher watch this I'm publishing you
know I got a publishing company now
watch this and to have the freedom to be
able to do that was phenomenal because I
knew I was like okay well we I I can
make this happen because yeah they're
looking at it going how the hell where
it where you can assist we're gonna
store a hundred thousand books how are
you gonna palletize books who's gonna
you with Joc are you gonna be in a
warehouse somewhere palletizing books
you know while you're trying to write
another book and do all the other stuff
that you're doing that's not gonna work
so they're in the back of their mind
they're thinking I'm an idiot yeah
they're thinking it's impossible which
is which is a common theme around here
people think things are impossible and
you know there's another thing I was
saying the other day and you were that
you kind of reminded me of this of when
you started down the path of hey I'm
gonna make easier and all of a sudden
they're telling you people were telling
you it's impossible to do this some it
seems impossible to do this and the
reason that that that that that that
propaganda is out there is because look
big corporations the best answer that
they can give to the American people and
they say hey why are you shutting down
this Factory the best answer that they
can give is oh it's impossible to
manufacture here that's what it is it's
impossible to manufacture that's their
answer that way they can save an extra
32 cents per item by having it
manufactured in China where they were
they they still have to
shipping they still have to pay customs
they have to pay to get it over there's
all kinds of but it's so it's not like
they're say it's not like oh those
laborers only get $1 a day so therefore
we're saving 80 or whatever $12 an item
no they're actually with all the other
costs they're saving 32 cents an item by
paying somebody over there a dollar a
day and my taking a job from an American
and sending it overseas so the best
answer that they can can give isn't well
we want to make an extra 32 cents an
item the best I answer that they can
give us this is impossible to do here
can't manufacture a manufacturer in
America anymore that's what that's what
we are being told we're being lied to
America is being lied to
and not and I honestly feel because of
the podcast I feel like you've made what
we're doing in Maine the tip of the
spear I mean in Maine is shaped like the
tip of the spear which is even more
badass and it is old-school New England
it is which is even more badass but it's
not impossible and like if you look at
like we're here at the immersion camp I
was sitting down with a woman she's in
California we're sit on the side of the
math she's from California and she's
she's a cop and she's just talking to me
about her struggles about media and how
they're making her out to be in her you
know in folks in law enforcement and
everything and and she said you know as
she's like what happened and I said and
just clicked I'm sitting here looking at
this mat full of a hundred two hundred
people from all different Creed's skin
colors backgrounds jobs from farmers to
huge businessmen scientists to surgeons
all on the mats
for a common goal to train and learn
jujitsu
isn't that what America is together for
a common goal isn't that how this
country was built isn't that how New
England was established when the
immigrants came in together for a common
goal and it's literally happening right
in front of me
I just I just connected into it and I
was just like what what's missing well I
can see here that this is all about
minds and hands right jiu-jitsu you know
learning jiu-jitsu it's not hard it's
hard on your mind it's hard on your body
it's hard on your hands you know and in
manufacturing is is the same thing it's
it's it's the same thing and just
understanding like and I know you know
you're from Maine and Connecticut in New
England and we both are and
understanding where we came from and
what was sacrificed so that we could get
here I feel like we've abandoned that
you know and I feel like jiu-jitsu is
like us this spark you know looking at
those mats just like the spark like whoa
wait a second I bet there's every type
of political affiliation on the mats
right now oh yeah for sure after all of
them unbelievable that these people are
here smiling and just and just sheer
enjoyment may be jiu-jitsu can solve the
world's problems
I don't know but but I do feel like
we've abandoned so much well also when
you take a kid and your kid says hey I
want to do this and you tell me you
can't do that what does that do the kid
what does that do the kids kids well
that's where we're at right now you
can't do this you can't do this in
America and another thing is when it's
like I want to build something you can't
do it think about that yeah you can't do
it and that is an attitude that used to
not even remotely exist in America we
were busy putting men on the moon and
building the best cars and the best
ships and the best planes in the world
and winning wars and getting after it
and all of a sudden we're looking around
going oh you can't you keep the before
what's the fundamental for all that
stuff built built it's build something
and all of a sudden you're being told
you can't build something the oh you
have to manufacture overseas
they manufacture better no no this is
our blood we build things and when you
take that away from someone what do they
got it's wrong it's just wrong so I
actually I actually like a little bit of
the propaganda it just helps for doing
if we can just sneak up behind these
folks and choke them out yeah
the and it doesn't stop there we're
gonna we're we're in a war on all fronts
you know we got on top of all this we
got origin labs yeah and we've put out
tons of new product at Origin labs from
but you know whatever me and echo talk
about that all the time the new products
and but from a business perspective I
think one of the biggest challenges has
been the go ready to drink in a can
again it was one of these things where
hey we want to make a drink that gives
you energy but is not freakin horrible
for you yeah which which which may seem
like oh that's impossible that's
impossible because you need it to taste
good so it's got to have sugar you've
got to have it not be refrigerated so
it's got to be have a bunch of chemicals
in it to keep it from going spoiled and
then you've got to put eight billion
grams of caffeine in it so it at least
convinces a person that's drinking 10
billion grams of caffeine a day that
this is actually hitting them so it's
all these hey that won't work no no no
and that was the first thing how do we
actually make something that I could
look at a person and be like you should
drink this it is good for you to drink
this it will help you in your life in
your brain in your athletic pursuits
right now that's a big step it is you
know what most funny is like I remember
the last conversation before we actually
pulled the trigger on making a decision
and you were like I'm not compromising
we're changing the category
like this is poison you know that this
category the energy train you had a core
energy drink it's just straight poison
and we're not conforming to the standard
and you you made like it's gonna be as
far as the caffeine thing when you kind
of set that bar like I was I was on
board you know and and I I you know the
thing is is like I'm not a big caffeine
drinker but and and I know you're not a
big caffeine drinker but literally like
I would never ever allow my kids to get
an energy drink are you kidding me
yeah ever I think if I gave my kid an
energy drink
there would be mayhem in the world
mayhem yeah so you know I mean just just
being able to make that decision we're
not gonna conform and we're not gonna
compromise you know I mean that started
the challenge yeah you know but and the
other big one was was how do we make
these things stay fresh right out the
normal chemicals that they add to all
these drinks that keep them from to keep
them from being spoiled and well that's
like well let's do what they do with mom
with milk pasteurized
pasteurization and so how many other
drinks are there that you go into a
store or you order or you pop open a can
and it's pasteurized what's the number
of drinks like that I think the number
is zero yeah number is zero again what's
the what's the business decision the
business decision well it's gonna cost a
lot more yeah it's gonna cost a lot more
to pasteurize these things it's gonna
cost a lot more to use monk fruit
instead of whatever the freakin cancer
carcinogens that they just pump into
those things no we're gonna use the best
ingredients so all those little
decisions along the way hey we could be
wrong actually we could be wrong
um it's worth the tuition payment I was
gonna say if we're wrong at least I'll
be able to sleep exactly and I think
that's what when you distill it down
that's what it that's what you get right
is hey you know you can cut corners and
the way you started this you can cut
corners here there the other place but
what is the right thing to do
you know like with the jeans what's the
right thing to do well build the product
that's gonna last a lifetime that's
actually the right thing to do that I'll
never fall apart right and it's the same
thing with with all the nutritional
stuff because there's so much junk and
you know my son 16 I will only let him
take mole for protein or war a kid
either one of those I'll let him take I
won't let him touch any of the shit he's
gonna be 17 my daughter's turning 14 you
know it's like there's things they're
exposed to and there's propaganda in
this industry pushing this poison at
kids and honestly like they're at the
point where they're mobile you know I
know your son's mobile to where they're
making decisions stopping at the store
grabbing things to drink grabbing snacks
and I actually am on them all the time
would you eat today would you pick up at
the store what you drink today you know
I'm on them about it because they know
how important it is to me that they make
good choices with the occasional you
know double cheeseburger and the dogs
which I'm a bar taken once in Ohio but
uh yeah there is a minaton in the
categories and in this industry in the
nutritional you know usually find people
looking at those things and I think that
ultimately ultimately honestly without
your podcast I think it would be almost
impossible I think it would be almost
impossible without without you
explaining the people what's going on
here well then you might as well sit
it's not really the podcasts the people
that are listening to the podcast sure
if not me
it's the people that are listen to
podcasts that go okay yep we're we're on
board that's what it is
yeah and so thanks to everyone that
listens to this podcast because
otherwise we wouldn't be doing much of
what we're doing right now no absolutely
I mean did you get all these like you
know these Netflix specials and stuff
you know unlike what makes you fat or
like the truth about sugar you know or
you know
all these things is all these news so
there's there is kind of awakening I
guess I would call it an awakening about
what you're putting in your body it's
happening it's happening and I think
you're a part of that awakening I think
you're a big part of that awakening
letting people know hey you got to watch
what you're putting in your body but I'm
gonna make something that I want to put
in my body you know and I think that's a
you know that value proposition it's
undeniable
you know it's undeniable and we're not
gonna compromise on that that's
undeniable yeah and if it doesn't work
out at least we did the right thing
that's undeniable to the cotton field
that's where you're gonna end up so you
can't argue with it yeah and I think
it's I think it's the right decision my
wife the other day I came home and she
says do you have a Vitamix blender or
like a high-speed blender do you have
those YUM Blendtec has it look at one of
those like big high speed blenders oh
like the ninja I don't know but it's a
big like it's almost like an industrial
blender so I have one of those and the
other day but I normally don't use it
because I just use a shaker cup right
when I'm making some milk of whatever
flavor so and everyone in my family just
uses his shaker Cup occasionally someone
decides to kick in the the Vitamix so I
come home the other day and my wife goes
you know she's like uh huh huh huh
and then she says I had strawberry milk
in the Vitamix and I said and and she
said she said this it's the best thing
I've ever tasted in my life
it's what my wife said seriously and you
know she just she said it was so frothy
so frothy and as I said what did you
have in it she goes just milk and milk
strawberry milk and when I saw it cuz my
wife you know she's uh she's a world a
worldly person I guess you know she
likes to got a fine palate and she likes
diff all different kinds with like I'm
not that right for me to be like this
day's good that has limited merit
and I share the wooden sword and they
need the wooden sword what sorts so I
can I can help assist painting the
picture of Helen go ahead you're like
hey we need to build a wooden sword
we're on the phone the other day oh wait
bill did well hit like we need to build
a wooden sword do like a special firm
try getting the Dragons little wooden
sword and I and we're sort of wooden
shield in the back in action choco
that's barbaric because I wanted little
kids to have shields and swords wooden
which is awesome it's like the only
thing I played with until I figured out
that there was a machine gun then I had
a mission right I think it's a great
idea for we should do that for like this
Christmas or something like build wooden
swords with the Mike even a dragon
shield yeah have a little dragon on it
yeah be badass dude if I was a kid Matt
got that yes I'd be chopping at
everything
yes I don't know that because I mean we
had wooden swords as kids yeah but and
then they turned them into foam yeah I
was gonna say that's the thing is now
they make them foam yeah because then
you can't hurt anybody which I get maybe
you need to maybe need to parent your
kids and say hey Billy
don't hit Jennifer in the head of the
sword like don't do that it's called
parenting let's try it or you just put a
helmet on them and put foam and
everything and put them in a padded room
and now we don't have to worry about it
Savage is anymore so shit all that stuff
together I mean it's it's growth right
now when you look at the growth right
now I mean do you see any hesitation in
the growth zero
do you see acceleration in the growth
yes the are you are you nervous I think
I I don't know nervous is the right word
you know I mean number one I love the
process and I hope the process never
stops I don't I mean to think of
something ending like what we're doing I
just you know I say well you you really
have four decades of opportunity and
I've told you this before
you know one of my advisers John I have
to introduce you to next time when
Farmington said hey hey you've got four
decades of opportunity you know your
first 20 years you're learning you've
got 40 years to do and then hopefully
you enjoy the fruits of your labor you
know and and I'm in I'm in the second
decade right 20 to 30 30 to 40 turn 40
in February second decade like the
process man the process is what gets me
excited being in the game you know not
standing on the sidelines not being a
former player watching you know the new
blood play you know I love being in the
game you know and and I think that to be
in the game you're gonna be a little bit
nervous you're gonna have butterflies
because that's what being part of the
team is that's what being in the game
means and if you and if you don't have
that then that you've you're arrogant
and or maybe you're complacent mm-hmm
right but if you're in the game you've
got to feel that thing that's driving
you to get up every morning you know and
and I love it I love it
you know that's truly my passion is
being in the game not what the not not
winning the game not winning the
championship not looking to to an end
goal like if we achieve this we've won
you know it's it's just it's just if we
achieve this what can we do next
exactly where can we go from there
exactly I look at one thing that I like
doing and I like being a part of and one
thing that I like about working with you
is it doesn't seem like I can say hey I
think we need to do this and I know that
it's gonna be really really hard but we
can do it and you're like oh yes we can
you know as opposed to the nine reasons
or the twelve reasons or the 47 reasons
why well you know there's this problem
there's that problem there's this
problem there's that problem I'd never I
never hear that from you I know you
don't hear it from me no it's hey this
where we're at this seems like it would
be crazy to do let's do it
yes here's how we can make it happen
yeah in in to touch on that and the fact
that there has been this propaganda
delivered to our minds over the past
twenty thirty years whatever it's been I
was talking to a woman recently and
she's the one that saved that first loom
when when the Chinese came in and they
purchased up this mill when Lewiston
Maine they pulled everything out she
saved this loom I had on my podcast
actually my name's Rachel and the
biggest thing that that built the
infrastructure for the New England Mills
were the canal systems and if you pulled
the stones out of like the canal system
in Lewiston you could build another
Great Pyramid if you pulled the granite
out of these canal systems you could
build another Great Pyramid think about
what they did a hundred years ago in
Lewiston Maine they built a Great
Pyramid in the form of a canal system
and they did it without technology they
couldn't look up leg twist in genes and
solve the problem right we can so to say
it can't be done I'd never say that
we've got technology we've still got
people that know we've got jets that can
get us you know you can jump in on a
JetBlue flight and get to Europe in
eight hours or 12 hours if you need to
go see how something works or if I need
to go to California if I need to just
drive to Lowell Massachusetts I mean you
have the opportunity to travel quickly
you're not getting on it on a boat on
the ocean and that's what they were
doing they were transporting this stuff
with a horse and buggy on Rails across
the ocean and you're telling me it's
impossible are you freaking kidding me
this is the easiest time we've ever had
to do this and that's why it's not crazy
because of what we do have we're
fortunate to be in a day and age where
we can get information like that you
know it's just a matter of
putting hands and dirt that's what
people are scared of you know they don't
know how good calluses feel if they did
and it'd be a different it'd be a
different world right now
so again fortunate and and being in New
England being in this part of of Maine
knowing that that feeling may have been
abandoned or the people may have been
abandoned and showing him no you haven't
been abandoned
actually this is cyclical and and we
know that we're still the best at this
let's just make it happen again let's
get back in the game let's get back on
the field let's make it happen again
just being part of that let's get to
work
let's get to work awesome seems like a
good place to wrap it up echo Charles
yes how's it going over there
pretty cool speaking of getting to work
yeah we like to work in various various
modalities yeah I've never heard that
word really modality lowdown oh geez
yeah and I love expanding vocabulary
explain it to me different modes
different modality different modalities
one modality might be we want to get
smarter right we want to train our brain
right we want to train our our aerobic
capacity sure we want to train our
defensive capabilities yes we want to
train our strength we want to train our
reflexes I mean we're just want to train
in a bunch of different modalities do
you know anything that really helps
across a broad spectrum spectrum of
modalities like that echo Charles yes
and what would that be well one is
jiu-jitsu growth in the emerging camp
immersing immersing herself rate that's
the word ranking merci yes yourselves
you know everybody's ripped off
immersion camp now oh really oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah all the who's who of
jiu-jitsu were doing immersion camps
okay yeah well good flattering that's
awesome yeah no mildly more people are
training yeah
immersing themselves in jiu-jitsu
because yes very useful as a modality of
improvement
sure mental physical anyway we're here
vocabulary vocabulary modality is
vocabulary modality well I'm just saying
we are apparently we're improving our
vocabulary tonight across the board yes
use an immersive modality to get
immersive mode oh yes so you know you
talked about the new rift key I agree
100% every element that you brought up
100% echo I'm gonna interrupt you even
though this is your time not a nice art
our time comes you know what we did for
you the last four days hmm did you
connect the dots huh wait no if I know
you know you got Aggie when you got here
yes you know who else got those keys
yeah Jocko what do you mean what color
was it
but did you see anybody else get a
blanky Jocko blue else hmm I don't know
all the other instructor all the other
black belts oh if you had peripheral
vision which I don't by the way you
would have known what was about to
happen
that's layers right there history we
caught was the escape Pete was concerned
yeah he goes if I give echo this do you
think he's gonna know and I was like now
he'll just think that it's the camp key
or something yeah oh no got his black
belt by the way for anyone that's
listening that didn't hear this yet and
we'll do a whole podcast about that well
we made 15 Blackie's for the expert the
black belt experts you being one of them
yeah XP holy cow then come on don't
leave your hand so cool and it's funny
cause it's like Yuto and you know
chocolate told me a few other things and
other stuff and it's like you know like
when you watch Fight Club you know here
watch a whole lot of toys you know like
you're like oh I didn't want to look at
you oh and you know at the end of Fight
Club this is big like you know what do
you call oh yes right then you watch it
again you're like oh I see a little bit
Darleen acting i thought i'm
experiencing right now with you guys
nonetheless you talked about the risky
black or otherwise that is a reinvented
scenario right there yeah really good
and the thing is i I do preferred and OB
over G something even that other one the
other the one that I got because I got a
rift and another one that looks good it
looks different it's a different kind
but it's also it's the same material
yeah yeah yeah that was special we yeah
yeah it's a special thing it's a
material material as a giant dragon
we've jet every reaches yeah IV gets the
primary mover in that gay feeling so
good yes I guess that the cut is also a
factor yeah but the bigger factor is
that material the textiles ridiculous it
like I I'd say it like dries as you
sweat yeah that's a great that's a weird
me in the in that you can it's dry it's
basically dry when you get done with a
spin cycle final spin yeah lint and
layers when you get done with that then
it's almost dry right then yeah you you
could put it on the mat so that's it for
anyone that had it Agee before like in
five years people be like oh yeah it
used to suck used to have to like dry
these things for 80 minutes right now
everyone's gonna be oh that must have
been horrible oh when I was a kid I used
to have the phones were attached to the
wall Oh people like oh that's very
horrible you know there's like oh I used
to get my key in the dryer for an hour
and a half to get it dry oh that must be
normal are we contributing to the
softening of society by making oh so we
can train more now there we go more jazz
well that saving power yeah it's green
right that's green yeah you get a rift
key yeah so yeah green Durga to unless
it makes me wanna do Morgie just that
little push and I think that's something
this is what this is not when you have
someone that is very focused on comfort
a little extra comfort goes along with
so if anyone's wondering which they
aren't I would assume they are not
wondering what do you get you get an
origin key because not just the rift
it's a whole spectrum while you're here
okay I'm gonna give you some scenarios I
just started you Jitsu I'm not looking
to compete I'm gonna train three times a
week my budget is tight what gear should
I get I would go with a comp atleta
okay which is still gonna hear the
performance or we have that warrior line
which is a lightweight Yi but it's more
built for warmer environments you know
the compact left that really is the
right key to go okay yeah I'm I'm
training six times a week I'm gonna
compete I have a tight budget six times
a week
you got to compete tight budget I'd
still go with a comp Athleta okay at
what point do I step up and get a rift
at what point do you want to improve I'm
gonna tell you honestly right now if my
budget was tight I would wait an extra
two months and get a rift
yeah well it's it's a game-changer
product you know it's not it's hard to
explain man like it like when you're
underneath somebody you know it like
we're an old key let's say you're
underneath somebody inside control
you've been sweating the whole match or
ten minutes in and you need to like
elbow escape or hip out and your arms
stuck inside the sleeve because of the
abrasion know the texture what you're
gonna feel is free you know so it gives
you an advantage in that regard if you
want to feel free on the mats even when
you're getting crushed and smothered get
a rift mm-hmm all right it's an
advantage it's it's it's a way to cheat
the system yeah okay yeah that's a whole
comprehend it's a whole yeah exactly
like the reason you like noogie so much
is you like that right the freedom of
movement and everything and in the
almost provides that for you you know
when you're in a major version of
covering up his arms as well well
because there's a massive
yeah all right also we got well we just
talked about jeans origin jeans order
those up we got t-shirts we got other
clothes and we got supplements do you
get yeah all the different supplements
yeah so I had I got the new which we
haven't talked about yet cold or is that
for a reason or we just now we're
talking about it now
boom so I got some that cold cold war
krill oil joint warfare good stack these
are like the the the prerequisite
supplements this is like to keep you in
the game like it doesn't matter you have
you can have huge strength all this
stuff but if you can't keep yourself in
the game like if you're on the sidelines
cause injuries whatever you're not
moving correctly think you're sick all
this stuff yeah it doesn't even matter
so anyway add that line it dawned on me
how these are the most important
supplements that there are in my opinion
yeah because without them you could
possibly not be in the game yeah even be
the strongest guy but you're not even in
the game you know you can't roll yeah
because whatever your neck is sore it's
in the joint we're friend I'm almost
ready to go there you go oh yeah you
know you did you ever tell you how the
cold the Cold War came to be because he
was getting off the airplane or
something or you were traveling along I
just went right and I'm like guys it was
almost got sick I need like a hyper
boost of you know the all the stuff that
prevents you from getting sick yeah and
Brian's like cool let me let me figure
it out yeah we ran it and then I tested
it and I'm like okay I've been traveling
whatever it was six weeks no sickness
that's that's like
and when I say sick you know you you
know when you travel and they're just
like your nose yeah you just you just
like wake up your mouth tastes like crap
yeah did you feel like you're about to
be a sick yeah that I gotta like that
yeah I don't like that it's pulling you
maybe not out of the game but it's
infringing on the game it's good yeah
infringement oh yeah so there's all that
stuff also what
Molk Molk
so to say you don't need milk okay maybe
maybe that but you kinda need a help so
that is that is the greatest name ever
monkey yes I mean it's you know there's
this borderline you know like just you
know we were talking the other day about
this borderline genius well they're just
the worst idea on the planet yeah Mulk
is in the genius medical honey you know
what I mean
it's it's genius
yeah it's it's fitting any it is
inspired by Mulk itself yeah
Moke came first and then milk came the
drink came yeah and it was so good I
remember telling you guys this is not a
pro this is not a protein to see all it
like a protein yeah this isn't a meal
replacement right this is its own thing
in and its taste to me like more the
influences in there for me were the monk
fruit yeah right Montmartre right right
and then kind of like Hulk mm-hmm right
cuz I knew we're going mint greens and
then of course Motorhead lot over the Oh
cuz that's just legit yeah yeah and they
asked lemme why he put the oom law over
Oh in Motorhead and he's that cuz it
looked cool like that there's the full
story on it as if we were all at home
not without so it's not an amulet is
that a different and now boom loud a
nebula isn't that like something you
wear around your neck yeah like a little
thing there I thought that those
crystals loud amulets limit no boom-boom
now yeah that's funny there you're like
and when you do it but put to put the oh
not above it put the two dots on single
I don't how to create and I'll do that
on the computer and you like hold down
this key
Moke was born or me a pretty important
part of my texting someone I like my
phone autocorrects like mo l k 2m o now
L K all caps
that's what it autocorrected I wrote
write milk so there's all of that extra
doesn't do that yet you can change it
and my Nasser the other thing I happen
when I write JJ it turns into jiu-jitsu
oh so that way I don't I type out
jiu-jitsu with a hyphen in there every
time you know you got to change the
keyboard nitrogen it says jiu-jitsu
gotta be honest I didn't know you could
do that yes you can
so there's probably the two that you
actually need just mulk in jiu-jitsu and
because you type molta so office i'm oak
so often in a type jujitsu so often
because even like responding on Twitter
it works so I just had JJ and says
jujitsu so you must get a lot of
questions like what do you need to be
successful in life like more super easy
also disciplined by the way yeah yeah
cannot say discipline and I will say
that is it cheating that today I'm going
on how many hours asleep
mmm none yeah not a lot and and and I
was tired coming when you when I said
today I has all planning I was like okay
tonight early oh and I'm gonna go to
sleep it I'm gonna wake up and I'm gonna
feel great and I said suit you wanna
record tomorrow you're like well tonight
in my in my mind I said to myself damn
but I wouldn't ever like reveal that one
way to say no I'm kinda tired I'm too
tired to record a podcast no not so but
I in case you can tell us in here it's
kind of tired coming in and then I drink
some of the D says it's coming a long
way you know we kept the powder of
course yeah right D and then what pills
yes powder pills yeah drink yes yeah the
discipline go and I wasn't gonna have a
go tonight yeah and then I was like I'm
going on choco podcast yeah I need a
little angel
I need your A game yeah
hey game Dave Burke Dave Burke good deal
we've recorded yeah as a matter of fact
we recorded the two podcasts
back-to-back and then took a couple days
off and then recorded another two
back-to-back ending before each podcast
he was taking to discipline go and he's
just like yeah 100%
he's like I'm bringing my a-game watch
this did you want to know something that
like feels real good my son came in and
he was meeting with your with dr. Luke
mmm I wanted him to learn a little bit
about you know medicines he's interested
in medicine and he he stayed for lunch
at the immersion camp here and he went
up and he saw the the dough cans all out
in ice or whatever and he's like God dad
can I have one of those and I said for
sure have it you know that's the first
time that's ever happened you know cuz
he's asked me in the past he's come up
to the counter with like a red bowl you
know like a monster or something gonna
put that shit back no you know and I was
like for sure man have grabbed one you
know it was good it felt good to be able
to do that and feel confident about it
how do you like it yeah he liked it yeah
oh for sure yeah
energy anyways cuz this one how old is
he 16 oh yeah he's owned do I know him
in his friend would like because they
had hands off two weeks ago before
double sessions for football they wanted
to come out surfing so bad and I almost
called you yeah I just didn't know how
crazy it was it was just like I would
literally call to me like hey I'm
sending the kids out to California to go
surfing awesome
I should have my son would just take him
yeah they he would not be responsible
with their safety because you know he's
another 16 years I've been jumping off a
cliff to do or whatever I would have
done it yeah yeah yeah anything else Oh
white tea chocolate tea don't be like
that
Chuck white tea always yes very good
certified organic by the way you know
any candidly lift 8000 which is a
positive thing yeah oh by the way double
blind we ran out of Jocko white tea this
second hey EV can't we brought enough
for the week I don't know how many
pallets that was we brought enough for
the window that the director here called
me said um
we only have a case of jakka white tea
left yeah so yeah we had another we had
some more delivered it's nice to be up
here having a giant warehouse with it is
a resupply I know yeah well you know we
figured how many cans we're gonna give
away that it was like everyone has you
know one or two a day well like five
thousand cans we're gonna go through
five thousand cans this week on the
house mm-hmm
come to the immersion camp but get some
free chalk or white tea big time also
Jocko has a store store of his own
online store Jocko store calm is where
you can get you know discipline equals
freedom represent while you're on the
path alright just leaking sputum shirt
with his head on it it says good also
short without is hair and this is good
if you don't if you don't like my head
yeah and you're sure I saw somebody yes
that liked your head that said although
it said Jack I was like I was like is
that choco store t-shirt is that Jacques
like no that's custom oh it's not it's
not Jacques store approved but it's
approved looking Jack there was another
there's another guy had a good shirt on
not approved yeah ripoff did you see him
no but that happened that feel bad and
it's got well if you see on Amazon
there's a bunch of like ripoffs and one
of them's like the whole good speed
right and it just says good really big
but then everything else is really small
and it's just an Amazon you know
somebody's making teespring or whatever
yeah yeah so anyways and I actually
didn't say anything to him yeah I
thought you know I can't be like bro
yeah you got it
on approval but yeah watch out for the
counterfeits
yeah but hey he's in a way he is
replicas action his intention is that's
why yeah
his attention is good you know I'm not
mad at him right I'm just mad that
someone's yeah some insurgents over
there trinitarian it they don't look
after two insurgents actually for the
latter happens to insurgents yes they
get killed
yeah thank you but yeah we got some
lightweight hoodies a lot of weight here
in Maine by the way oh really
we're in Maine it's summer exactly right
um that's what I'm saying I mean it's
not heavy heavy heavy function func
function even though lightweight hoodies
do have function aesthetically and raw
functionality I'm just saying
doesn't that lightweight hoody show your
biceps yes I like that you were a
hundred percent honest right there yes
cause it's like it's good it's that I
you know I know anything you know what I
know you appreciate the lightweight
hoody I do because it has fashion I do
value
yeah I think a lot of people don't I
don't wear it as well as you yet but I'm
working on my biceps again yeah
you're looking good by the way thank you
many people have approved that hoodie
while I had it on I approved the
lightweight hoodie they like the light a
lot of us like the lightweight lights
there I do oh yeah veto it it's
completely awesome
anyways hats hoodies all kinds of good
stuff chocolate or calm the rash guards
wear the rash guards made by the way Oh
american-made oh like none other than
örjan main origin way origin USA just
origin yeah subscribe to the podcast
also subscribe to Pete's podcasts
respond class is called hands and a
light you talk about various jujitsu
things you talk about business things
you talk about history things would you
say your podcast is kind of like my
podcast - war yeah it would be more
around like taking back America versus
war but the struggles of you know from
an industry angle yeah I would say yeah
and it's a lot of storytelling you know
and oh it's pretty it's pretty cool ya
know it's it's it's a great podcast
it's called hands and daylight this
podcast is called jaakko podcast echo
doesn't think you've subscribed yet
if you haven't echo is disappointed he
would like you to subscribe right now
well you know let's put kind of strongly
but yeah cool there you go
subscribe is cool it's good to subscribe
I'm saying joke with everybody I was
watching some YouTube video the other
day they were test driving a car and it
was a pretty good video like they were
they were entertaining guys they were
funny and I was like oh these guys are
kind of cool like this is these guys are
cool and it's a good subject you know
you're like watching their given I mean
I like cars right everyone likes cars
right and they're test driving a car and
I was thinking I was actually thinking
if echo and I were doing this would be
kind of fun like remember when we test
drove a car I was test driving car you
happen to be with me yes and it was kind
of fun right yeah yeah now imagine if we
there was cameras in there and we were
just talking about how cool that car was
right and I was thinking that I was like
wow this is pretty cool this guy and in
the middle of it they just start going
um and by the way if you you know smash
the like button and subscribe to us
right now and go check our patreon
account and I was like I stopped the
video cuz they came at me like that so
we have a joke or we joked about and
then I over used the joke where he was
he said he got told me live like hey
that's not funny anymore
so I was just about to do it again and
that's constrained myself see it comes
full circle now it is still kind of
funny because then there's a warrior kid
podcast too so don't forget about that
for your kids and don't forget about the
Irish Oaks ranch calm young eight and
making soap on his farm with American
hands as bad as an American goes run in
a business he's now 13 he started it
when he was like 11 so cool he makes
that soap so you can stay clean yeah
YouTube yeah YouTube video version in
this podcast go and see what Pete looks
like big tall strong man masculine guy
I'm just saying your bigs I don't know
and some whatever you know debatable but
nonetheless if you want to see what he
looks like yeah we have a youtube
channel Josh
go podcast YouTube channel also some
excerpts on there you know cut off the
podcast I like what you've been doing
lately with everything
I like the content you know Paul knows
excerpt the snippets out and it's
awesome
do you prefer if it's just like me
talking or do you prefer if I talk while
things explode in the background yeah I
do like I do like both but for me I like
when you're talking but for echo I like
when things explode like when you're
like that's incorrect
hopefully they don't like pull down your
post on their post on Instagram but like
the other day when you're like yeah when
you do that stuff you read I'm good so
I'm gonna keep that up and the more
explosions are the more better that's
what someone told me yeah straight out
like cool Jocko says cool stuff I get it
but the way I kind of kind of distilled
it down as far as like the format is if
you're saying something important and
it's kind of longer than one minute I
won't put any explosions on it cool okay
under one minute explosions and flames
by the way we got psychological warfare
little moments of weakness that you
might experience during your day in your
brain in your own little brain the
little debates that are happening the
weak voice versus the strong voice
sometime the weak voice gets stronger
and it needs to catch a beatdown
that's when you pet press play on your
iPhone that little psychological warfare
track that tells you know you're not
gonna skip leg day you're gonna go get
it psychological warfare that's mp3
itunes google play all those mp3
platforms if you want a visual version
of that that you can hang on a wall
functional graphics go to flipside
canvas calm dakota meyer my brother he's
making these canvases and you know where
they're made oh they're made in America
if that's right what about what about
our friend dak yeah
so can we talk about the special project
is there any reason not to know let's do
it
well Dakota Dakota Meyer you yeah
helicopter yes he's like he's a girl
that's what he needs
I know he's like Rob Ryan gotta come
down to Texas I'll come and pick you up
I'm like cool get your license first oh
man those kind of helicopters that no
freaks me out the that kind of
helicopter when you go into it I've been
in them before they seem like you
remember when you built a model when you
were kid you get it yeah you ever do a
build a model when you're kid it was
little plastic pieces and they stuck
them together with test testers glue
yeah it seems like this is one elevation
above that just one it seems like
someone made this thing out of little
right erector set pieces that's what it
seems that's what those helicopters feel
like when you get in them and when you
fly them that's what they feel like you
if you don't like flying
you're not gonna be game for that
especially with the Kona try will
decline the class what's you waiting
nine hundred pounds so that would be
like flying lopsided you know he's a
savage yeah and uh we're actually gonna
get and do that energy drink for him
there we gotta come up with a better
name than energy drink for the neodo
what do you wish we'll think about
hanger but but it's gonna be called back
savage dak Savage Doc Savage I like it
so we know I know I didn't get this job
approved but the background is on it
scam home oh yeah no no it's a light
week you know I seen it okay yeah you
said it to me go order either you were
beat it'd be a little murder senator oh
yeah I guess yeah yeah no it looks
awesome yeah that's going into
production pretty quick well how would
you describe that flavor well he really
likes Dr Pepper mmm interesting so it's
like I'm like a where they call wine
good cherry like jagged oh yeah black
cherry vanilla there you go awesome also
on it for fitness gear kettlebells
battle ropes rings maces steel
you know all this kind of but you call
that New Age workout is of no interest
direction option yeah yeah that's like
old school right back right yeah
it's weird especially like kettlebells
how they kind of came back like with a
vengeance yeah they did oh yeah
did I ever send you will let their
medicine ball that we were making no not
send you one but I saw one in the
mountain training facility okay there
you go and had a good workout in there
the other morning yeah yeah I did have a
good work yeah we heard morning this is
the day that echo slept you okay so echo
was we we had a long we flew from
California to Boston we recorded our
podcast in Boston once we got done in
Boston we drove it was a early late
night early morning drove to Maine to we
stayed up late that night for some
reason oh oh yeah then we went to your
house
we hung out then we went back and so we
got to bed it wasn't that late overnight
we had to bed at like 10 o'clock 10:30
so I wake up in the morning I'm in Maine
I'm stoked I'm at the mountain training
facility and I go downstairs you got and
it was one of those things I just had
just figured out a good little workout
with the equipment that Janet went you
guys had a Bulgarian bag a 28 kilogram
kettlebell which is which is in between
I have 24 I have 32 so I had a little
meat you know that's does a little mix
it up I was gonna up the reps you know
and to try some other movements and so
I'm down there getting after it's 4:30 I
get done with that and I was cranking up
some music I was cracking up so rock and
roll yep yep a little some Danzig some
Caius and then it just playing whatever
I get done I go upstairs shower get done
and I have two documents that I got to
edit so I edit these documents and it's
you know it takes a while to put to
legit full documents I'm editing get
done with that and then I look at my
watch that was the morning we talked for
like two hours we talked for two hours
after that don't work I went for a run I
actually fell down you would towards
your old house yeah I went for a nice
long run I get done with all this
stuff and I I look at my watch and Dean
and an echo are still asleep and I go
that's weird that they're still asleep
and it's - it's 12:40 in the afternoon
and at first I no movement I said what
that's like so I sent him a text like
hey are you guys alive like kind of
calling them ahead and then I think to
myself wait a second
maybe they it's been 14 hours they must
be dead
they must be dead and I got like a
little nervous I think the carbon
monoxide poisoning yeah like I get it
okay I sleep less right than a normal
person cool I got some weird genetics
cool I sleep five hours this is three
times that right there's no way a person
can sleep that long I think this carbon
monoxide pores never know five whole
bodies I go in there and they're just
like echoes you know I go this is really
tired on it yeah on it let's go get the
cool stuff kettlebells they did come
back I do have a 28 pound or kilogram
kettlebell that's like what 60 - I liked
it man from oh yeah I kind of liked
having a little intermediary the problem
is I can go overboard with stuff as we
know well you know increase until you
die no no no just get like I'll have
every kettlebell imaginable oh yeah I do
I have the whole spectrum and there's a
but man it's worth it because like you
can modulate like throughout the whole
workout especially if you're doing
kettlebells which I highly recommend by
the way do kettlebells Pete I've just
started recently just like swinging them
yeah yeah you should be swinging a nice
light weights you got your back
situational swing a nice light weight
and it is so good for you man it feels
good you know here's the thing about
kettlebell swings you won't feel this
cuz you're going light but you think to
yourself oh I got whatever I got my 40
kilogram kettlebell no factor I'll swing
this thing you know it's gonna be pretty
easy and the first six of them it is
easy you're like what is this
yeah by the time you get to 16 you're
like okay yep then you get to 24 and
you're like okay
yeah it's it's it kicks you yeah good
even on the rowing machine
you got a different rowing machine but
on a concept to mow rowing machine when
you start you're like I'm gonna blast
this thing out and it takes a minute for
your for your energy system what's that
first energy system that you're using
with a people yeah like the ATP that
immediate sprint one and you're like
using that and but then it gets used up
but yeah your anaerobic that's what your
anaerobic system gets used up and then
you're just sucking but you think you're
Superman for the first you know meters
do you usually well it just depends what
I'm doing just depends what I'm doing
you know and I use it usually for
sprinting I'm usually not in they're
gone 20 minutes I've been a little bit
minute when I couldn't run cuz my knee I
was rowing a little bit more and I was
using minimum I wasn't going a full
range of motion
but anyway so how long you go I go 30
minutes yeah that's cool I try to do
8,000 meters yeah that's quite a minute
that's just consistent so yeah yeah
that's like dude I did one the other
night because that the the mountain
retreat where you had the great workout
that was our original factory all the
big timbers and stuff of course I been
working out in the evenings and I did
one the other night it was I got home it
was really late and I just kept all the
lights out and I rode in the in the
pitch-black could you see the monitor or
anything no and I just rode until you
felt I rode and I actually rode against
my shadow because there was just a
little bit of light behind me casting a
shadow on the wall and I just just like
chasing my shadow and it was the best
workout I had no idea how long I had
rode
I just knew like 30 minutes I said the
time before in the pitch black and it
was freakin phenomenal so you did set
the timer my phone timer yeah it just
went off went off boom so and you had no
idea there was just a puddle anger and
sweat animal so I and Dad it was kind of
kind of spiritual right
like hey I got some books I got a new
book leadership strategy and tactics
Field Manual that is available for
pre-order right now if you want to get
it first a dish then you shorter right
now if you don't well it doesn't really
matter what you do is it a hard copy or
oh yes it is yeah yeah it's a hardcover
book yeah it's not the same size as the
original field manual it's smaller so
that people can carry it that's one of
the things that when you look to field
man you like well do we want to be able
to carry it I'm like yeah probably this
one is to be used in the field
leadership what are some like that's the
chapter name so it's it's broken down
like this there's 80 chapters holy shit
yeah there so there's 80 chapters but
they're short got it hitting chapters
like where you go and it's all about
leadership it's my boss is micromanage
me what do I do
how would this work for for some of my
my floor managers because they're
plugged into the training program the
Echelon front training program the
online program which has been awesome
you know but it would be nice because
they can't they can't like be on that
well they're operating we call operators
right well they're operating but if they
did have like a book that it was like
that because what it is that's what I
made it yeah and another thing is I used
to be able to say if someone said hey
you know as far as practical application
of these principles oh yeah what do I do
if ma if I got a guy that's if I got a
guy that's got a lot of potential but
he's not doing what he should be doing
what should I do
and I used to just be able to say hey
just listen you know go-go's in the
podcast and you when there was 20
podcast it's like oh cool you know
you've listened the podcast now if I
tell someone oh the answer is in the
podcast I'm basically assigning them
over 500 hours yeah yeah inappropriate
right so I had to take all this
information and like distill it down so
you could just look it up it's highly
indexed okay so you can just look up
that's cool the subject and boom go so
it's totally pragmatic so would if for
for like our our managers our floor
manager
would you say that the book replaces the
online training or they serve two
different purposes they serve two
different purposes here's the facts
you-you-you want it you don't get good
at anything through one direction of
training how much better you at juju how
much better you at an armlock if you
learn it from four different instructors
oh yeah you're your husband how much
better are you at any learning a subject
if you learn three books about a subject
instead of one
oh yeah infinitely better it's not just
better it's not it's not it's
exponentially better because you're able
to compare and contrast what you learn
the first time with what you learn the
second time you see it from another
angle so you see a one-dimensional you
see a two-dimensional on the third time
you read a book about the same subject
you see it through the third dimension
the fourth time now you're seeing the
fourth dimension of things and that
continues to go so all these things so
they need both all these things are an
effort to give the different
perspectives and different angles on
these subjects because the better you
get at them just like training jiu-jitsu
if if you the more you the more time you
spend on bottom and inside control the
better you get it handling it the more
time you spend dealing with different
leadership problems the better you get
at it the more different angles you can
see the better you get at it so that's
the purpose but I would say the initial
ideal is like listen people need to be
able to apply these principles they need
cuz here's another thing people read
extreme ownership they they actually
understand the principles they can
explain the principles back to you but
as far as overlaying those principles
and even overlaying the examples onto
what they're dealing with
sometimes people sometimes some people
have a hard time making those things
overlay properly and so here it is
instead of saying here's the principle
overlaid on your thing it's like here's
what it will look like right now when
you put it there
it's more it's more direct you don't
have to you can do less you can you can
you can it's
it's more direct so that's the
leadership strategy and tactics Field
Manual I I did just get a note from my
publisher and they said this was superb
super her and you know that's pretty
cool you get you know a bunch books and
some what this book is superb
that's especially from a publisher that
reads books all the time and they don't
have to send you that note like this is
from someone at the publishing company
that doesn't doesn't just send out notes
right so specifically I probably read it
in or applying the strategies yeah yeah
they're probably like okay I'm gonna
he's just now yeah totally also where
the warrior kid 3 where there's a will
you can get that right now way the
warrior Kid 1 marks mission that that
how many people at camp how many books
how many warrior Kid books have you seen
any sign of camp all of them yeah all of
it
laughter people after people after
people those books are having such an
incredible impact it's so amazing to see
I don't think there's anything that
makes me feel better at this point in my
life then then getting showing us a
parent showing me a video of a little
kid doing a pull-up and then looking at
the camera and saying I'm a warrior kid
yeah that's my task this doesn't get any
better than that I've been signing work
kid books too but that's awesome
I didn't write it by the way but they
signed a few that's awesome I took the
picture in the back there's something
they're gonna make a contribution
gotta make a movie we're working it
we're working it now yep and then just
blink was freedom Field Manual that's
another field mate oh this one's
directed at you individually how to get
after it the audio version is on mp3s
it's not on audible extreme ownership
and dichotomy leadership the first two
books where you learn the principles you
have to know the principles if you don't
know the principles applying them it
doesn't make any sense to you so extreme
ownership and the dichotomy leadership
get these principles into your head so
that you can apply them at your business
at your life they work they work that's
another thing I hear all the time from
people they say you know I have been
using it it works it works they'll give
me a specific example of us how how it
works
I had this clown I had this customer
called me and they said bla bla bla bla
and I said you know what that's my fault
and they said you know what I probably
should have given you a better heads up
it works it works we got our leadership
consultancy which is called echelon
front go to Ashlyn front comm if you
have problems in your organization of
any kind of any kind they are leadership
problems and you need to help get your
leadership squared away and aligned and
that is what we do a national on Front
National Front comm
we got EF online which do you go do you
share the size of clients you work with
like do you let people know like you
guys are on the road or I should say
around the world all the time helping
companies yeah become better leaders big
companies like sometimes we're on the
phone you're like I'm here then I say
like oh I'm here yeah like do people
actually understand the impact you're
just having on leadership in corporate
America America as a whole maybe I don't
do a great job of explaining that we
work with the largest companies in the
world yeah and we also work with smaller
companies as well and if you're so small
that it's out of the price range for you
as a company guess what we got something
called the muster you can sign up and
come to one of our musters where we
teach these principles you can bring
three four people and your leadership
team if you've got a company of you know
what 20 people you can bring three four
of your leaders and you kind of get that
initiated and then you can use something
called EF online which you are using
yeah we use it yeah and my you know and
it's nice because before like it's
always come to come to me come to me
come to me come to me
you know and helping helping are our
leaders which is basically everybody in
the factory become better leaders and to
learn leadership principles but now they
can go online and then they come to me
with questions they have right so is
honestly it doesn't take as much time
which for sure wonderful so the
efficiencies are going up you know I did
at first they were they you know a few
like Jill the one the stitching here in
Jan and a few others they're like
when can we start can we do this on
company time that was the first question
can we and of course we don't have
computers set up and everything and I
was like yes yes you can because I
wanted them to know that I'm invested in
this for sure
and once I land so I was using the
leadership techniques to teach
leadership yes and then once they saw
that I was in then they went home and
then they got online yeah and I was like
now they're doing it on their own time
because I was invested yeah and I'm
doing it on this on our time of course
son company you want think of the cost
benefit and the ROI we get that origin
you get at origin because of the
leadership it's just the way it is yep
yep absolutely it's good
awesome awesome stuff what else we got
we got so yeah if you can't come too if
you can't if you can't higher echelon
front go to the muster the next one is
taking place December 4th and 5th and
Sydney we're about to release the
follow-on dates for 2020 as soon as we
can
the thing is here's the deal they all
sell out they all sell out 100% and it's
not like hey it sold out but we can fit
in eight more people know we've sold out
and we no one else will be coming so one
hear a crazy statistic yes somebody said
to me today you know how many Americans
are outside cast 300 million Americans
they're like and how many people are at
this immersion camp and I said well 300
per session he's like so one in a
million
and I said yeah and we had to cut
registration off three months early
mm-hmm how many people do you let in to
the muster it looks like it depends on
the size of the venue but it's anywhere
between 700 and 850 but the Australian
one we have less we have a smaller
vendor we just couldn't get the size
venue that we need so we have less but
so two in a million you're letting yeah
something like that you know what I mean
it's yeah like it's it's as value-added
is ridiculous yeah yeah so come and
check out the monster and then of course
we have EF overwatch which we already
talked about on this podcast taking
people that have experience in
leadership and putting them into
companies in the civilian sector so if
you're a company that needs
leadership or you're a leader that needs
to move on to your next mission in life
go to EF over watch.com and if you
haven't heard enough of us if you
haven't heard enough stories about
jiu-jitsu shoes jeans whatever else you
can find us on the interwebs we're on
Twitter one Instagram
we're on dine fusion Bock the face
before he is on Instagram
he's at I was forced to go on Instagram
but now that's your primary no I mean
I'm yes not prime what do you mean by
problem that's what you seem to do your
most activity on you think where do you
think you do most activity on origins
oh no I'm saying Instagram yeah
Instagram on Instagram is where you do
most of your yes I have you do Twitter
yeah as I throw Twitter your direction
yeah people say you throw it out I hate
one of the jeans coming out I say as
soon as or at origin BJJ releases on
yeah and then I'll jump on then you'll
do no I do most my activity on Instagram
so and those two are at origin USA and
then also at Pete M
Roberts yeah Pete and Pete dot m dot
Roberts that's a pain in the ass isn't
it yeah somehow there's two people that
got their names one's name is a deco
Charles and one's name is at Jocko
willing and all the stuff that we're
doing right now we would not be doing
any of it without our military out there
protecting the freedoms that we have so
thank you all for holding the line and
also to our police and our law
enforcement and our firefighters and our
paramedics and our EMTs and our
dispatchers and the correctional
officers and the Border Patrol and the
Secret Service and all the first
responders that are out there you're the
ones that are protecting us here
at home and protecting our way of life
so thank you for what you do and to
everyone else that's out there there is
much to be done and I'll tell you what
no matter what you hear about how much
competition there is in the world the
fact of the matter is there aren't that
many people that are actually willing to
do the work it's you so get up get to
work and get after it and until next
time this is Pete Roberts and Ecko and
Jocko out